bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de slap shade lapchak le réseau social
qui continue de cartonner
ouais mais pas exactement on va parler
des lunettes connectés de snapshot qui
elle cartonne beaucoup moins et pourtant
hirsi y persiste avec une version 2 les
spectacles deux et on en parle plus
le chat je pense que vous êtes dessus de
plus en plus de personnes viennent
dessus ça résout qui est vraiment cool
ils ont vraiment créé quelque chose
facebook est voulu et racheter un temps
non que nenni ils ont refusé du coup
facebook a répliqué l'idée un peu d
stories sur facebook sur instagram sur
vos de sap s'il avait la lune il le
mettrais sur la lune s'il avait je sais
pas quoi il le maître est partout voilà
ça c'est du point de vue en tout cas
snapshot continue dans sa lignée a déjà
sorti une version 1 2 cv de connecter
les spectacles numéro un on peut pas
dire que ce soit vraiment un grand
succès pas même plutôt dire que c'est
plutôt un fiasco
et pourtant ils sortent des versions
numéro 2 des lunettes de soleil hyper
cool hyper sexy pour pouvoir filmer
faire des photos les partager votre vie
beaucoup plus facilement ce qui est
quand même dingue c'est que ces lunettes
de soleil il ya de moins en moins de
fabricants qui croit on avait google à
une époque avec ses google glace glace
mon physique
je voulais me glace je voulais essayer
puis au final ça fait un bide monstrueux
sais pas si vous avez déjà vu quelques
infos sur la glace à san francisco il ya
des bars dans lesquels les goûts glace
ont littéralement interdite parce que
pour le respect de la vie privée donc
l'élite est connecté c'est toujours un
petit peu délicat
du coup est ce que ces spectacles numéro
2 vont enfin marché ou alors est-ce que
m'envoie un autre stade chat va les
enterrer une bonne fois pour toutes ça
peut pas le dire parce que on n'est pas
de 20g pas une boule de cristal dans
lequel je peux vous gala venir de la
tech ainsi seulement en jeu ça serait
formidable je pourrais vous dire tout ce
qui va se passer dans les années à venir
avant ça très clairement c'est pas le
cas
en attendant le produit il faut le
reconnaître on lui-même est cool et sexy
on peut faire plein de choses avec et
justement on va regarder un petit peu
tout ça il faut quand même savoir que la
première version des lunettes de
snapshots et vendu à 150 mille
exemplaires on peut se dire 150 mais
exemplaire c'est pas mal ça fait
beaucoup mais du point de vue de
snapshot c'est vraiment un fiasco un
vrai bide qui leur a fait perdre près de
40 millions de dollars
alors puisqu'on parle de snapshot vous
donner quelques chiffres snapshot en
2017 c'était 173 millions d'utilisateurs
actifs par jour 173 millions de
personnes qui viennent sur snapshot
parle même pas du nombre d'inscrits en
son sein bien parle de personnes qui
viennent tous les jours et qui
l'utilisent 173 millions 3 milliards de
snap envoyés par jour c'est que vous
avez 173 millions
on voit en tout et pour tout 3 milliards
de snap par jour et en tout 5 millions
de snap envoyés via les lunettes
spectacle autant dire que c'est pas
énorme
donc ça peut paraître énorme mais cent
cinquante mille exemplaires 5 millions
de slap je puis vous assurer qu'à
l'échelle de snapshot
c'est vraiment pas grand chose alors du
coup ils sont nés pour cette version
nous on va changer un peu les choses
on va changer on va revoir un peu le
design on va faire un design un petit
peu plus discret la caméra va être un
peu plus légères on va enlever le cercle
jeunes au niveau de la caméra
sauf que quand vous l'allumez que vous
filmez par contre pour respect de la vie
privée vous avez un petit rouge qui
s'allume donc à je peux voir qu'un homme
qui est en train de filmer là bas vous
dévoiler l'envers tu fais une page n'est
pas autorisée mais ça c'est plutôt bien
parce que de les voir en vrai respect de
la vie privée avec tous ces objets
connectés pour le coup elles sont
étanches c'est quand même relativement
bas l'eau pour des lunettes de ne pas
être étanche à vous dire effectivement
c'est des lunettes de soleil
s'il pleut quel intérêt d'aller dehors
avec mes ailes de soleil je suis
d'accord dans l'absolu vous avez raison
mais une averse tropicale peut toujours
arriver à la cci je suis un peu de
mauvaise foi je dois le reconnaître mais
c'est vrai que c'est un point positif
parce que c'est ce qui met en avant pour
toutes les personnes qui sont en est et
qui veulent aller dans la piscine
plongée faire les cons dossier ça ils
risquent pas de vie meilleures lunettes
écoutez quand même sur la version numéro
un quand même 150 euros la 175 euros
pour la version 2 donc autant vous dire
que l ont plutôt intérêt traitant je
serais content de les faire tomber dans
la mer ou dans la piscine
alors vous pouvez prendre des photos et
des vidéos en hd vous pouvez faire des
vidéos de 10 secondes et vidéo de 30
secondes et bien sûr des photos à gogo
elles sont disponibles en 3 couleurs
vous avez les onyx les rubis et les
saphirs et en deux types de verres vous
pouvez faire jusqu'à 70 vidéo en une
seule charge
et grâce au boîtier qui inclut avec vous
pouvez mettre jusqu'à 4 charge
différente si vous les avez jamais
utilisé vous avez vos lunettes débute à
proximité de votre smartphone elle se
connecte vous pouvez soit directement
envoyé viasna chat soit les enregistrer
par exemple dans vos pellicule si vous
avez un smartphone ou dans votre galerie
si vous avez un smartphone android ou
que sais-je encore donc on va en tout
cas qui a une vraie volonté pour
snapshot de se dire non non nous on
continue à y croire
effectivement les spectacles ou un non
pas trop marché peut-être que le marché
n'est pas encore mature peut-être que
les gens n'y croient pas plaire il faut
qu'ils en voient davantage
à droite à gauche et que petit à petit
ça va évoluer ça va prendre
donc affaire à suivre d'ailleurs dit moi
vous est ce que vous avez eu déjà les
lunettes de snapshot les spectacles si
c'est pas le cas est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu des personnes emportées en
dehors de youtube en dehors des youtuber
khiroun parce que ça ne compte pas un
youtube heures ne compte pas dans vos
amis dans votre cercle proche est ce que
vous avez déjà vu des personnes qui
avaient ces fameuses lunettes spectacle
de snapshot
et si c'est pas le cas est ce que vous
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter par
ces lettres
est ce que vous seriez prêt à mettre 100
75 euros pour acheter les lunettes
connectés snapshot pour être toujours
plus connecté sur snam chat et partager
votre monde est votre vision directement
sur sap chaque vous marquez tout ça en
commentaire comme d'habitude vous invite
à laisser des jolies pousse à vous
abonner parce que vous allez voir on va
parler toujours plus de teck a plein de
choses à dire plein de nouveautés qui
arrivent de tous les côtés que l'emploi
y en a trop donc voilà rester connecté à
très bientôt que j'embrasse mon message
ciao
[Musique]